i want to start with a sincere thank you
i know how hard it is based on
conversations i've had with many
different people in the industry about
doing an animated show like this and
every episode of this show
i was going to swear i really enjoy your
show and i want to thank you so much for
the hard work that it takes to pull this
thing off so
for people that don't understand how
something like this is made what do you
think fans of solar opposites might be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show
you know i know one thing that might
surprise people is that our actors are
never in the same room together
they they are performing individually
and they are being mixed together but it
sounds so natural and so conversational
and we were actually doing records like
that before the pandemic started and
it's what allowed us right when we went
into the pandemic to move records to
over zoom uh to continue making the show
and and just to continue making it sound
the same way it was before
yeah i would only add that we're you
know it takes so long it takes a year to
make a show so we're already very deep
into season four at this point yeah
that's another one yeah like we're yeah
that's an interesting one that people
and then also we write the show from uh
a bunker that's in texas very like i
think it's like an old uh uh nuke
silence yeah it's like really deep in
the ground we're not allowed to take
prep and it's got a lot of asbestos in
it but that actually it's fine
i think it makes us yeah it makes us
more creative i was going to say the
ideas probably stem from that actually
oh absolutely yeah it might be affected
we do all have one giant gummy bear we
eat we roll it up and we smoke the
asbestos yeah yeah yeah i don't do it at
home though because it's not uh it's
only for us very high we're okay
it's high quality yeah it's like
hollywood texas we get it from like a
really nice like asbestos head shop in
westwood yeah i see the way it is in the
writers room you can actually say here
since no one's recording that the reason
everyone records separately is that the
cast hates each other no no we actually
really truly sincerely love each other
and to and today is a great like fun
uh day where we all get to just be
together cause of covid we like i record
at my house you know which is maybe
another thing people what's the address
uh i live at blah blah blah
in texas
and texas in a silo um uh underground
but uh no but like yeah it's it's it's
just we're all so [ __ ] busy oh sorry
we're all we're also ding darn busy ding
darn is that gonna be the new yeah we're
doing darn uh we're dang darn busy here
can you make ding darn sound like really
offensive like we're all i'm not gonna
try it anyways um
yeah and then uh so being able to hang
out with everybody has just so been so
fun like and we haven't had comic con
for years now so it's like
yeah it's we love each other as the very
short answer and that's the truth yeah
and we're so lucky to have the the group
we have it's a very the the um
and as mike said we all record
separately but when it gets cut together
there's a chemistry
that we have
clicked on
that is just so magical and it's and
it's like we roll the 20 you know if
you're a d d guy like holy [ __ ] with our
cast it's insane also the the entire
cast everyone's voice is so perfect for
the character like uh and you can anyway
um you guys have a
halloween special coming out later this
year oh too spooky don't get too spooky
it does not like halloween is it yeah
yeah corvo is very that's good the plot
is corvo is incredibly scared of
everything to do with halloween
including candy corn and like the little
plastic spider rings too spooky too
spooky too much yeah the the the
previous halloweens the previous special
i believe was like a normal episode have
you ever it was christmas it was a
christmas special yeah yeah but you mean
it wasn't the same
time yeah oh oh yeah yeah yeah this one
is the same runtime this one's 12 hours
long no no no no yeah it's just i'm just
wondering if you guys have thought about
that that's my they're coming they're
coming to get me yeah
i ordered some postmates by elevator so
they're just gonna they're gonna land no
no
i meant a helicopter
security in to make sure you don't want
to say that you have a funny story of
why they're that length i want to hear
it so we originally got picked up for
two seasons of eight episodes and we're
making second season
and we write the eight episodes and i'm
looking around the writers room and i'm
like i feel like we got one more i feel
like we can do another one so i got hulu
on the horn you know just like
president three three eight three eight
who whatever good man wonderful man and
i was trying to hulu is so supportive of
us i was like hey
we have a couple more weeks with the
writers we've written all the episodes
what if i told you we could whip
together a christmas special really
really fast can we just have the budget
for that
and hulu was like hell yeah you know and
just i've never been on a show where
somebody's just like yeah increase your
order by one because you asked you know
and so that's where the first christmas
special came from and then when we did
the next season
they were like we're going to give you
12 episodes we want one of them to be a
special you know so we're just going to
continue moving forward we're writing
one for season four as well so we're
always going to do 11 and then a special
and then every time we're gonna do our
solar weird
jokey version of what a tv special
should feel like but i think you were
gonna you were gonna ask do if we would
ever do a movie or something well not
even a movie but like one of the things
about streaming is that you really don't
have a finite like you don't have to hit
a certain run time but something i've
been saying a lot but not necessarily
with these folks but like yeah but
budgetarily we do every second of
animation on screen yeah that is cost
money and so we get to a point where if
we have a longer episode it means we
have to have a shorter episode or
something that has more reuse so like
we're never fighting the streaming world
we're really just fighting
trying to get the show done with the
amount of money we have for you yeah
it's it's okay oh no i mean everyone
knows the the good good fast cheap you
know pick two kind of thing it's it yeah
so anyway blah blah blah go ahead no i
was just gonna say that at the beginning
we were like we can make them as long as
we want because we're on streaming but i
think with comedy especially with
animation we just kept editing them down
and they always ended up being about 22
or 23 because you wanted to do you
wanted to just you don't especially our
show you want to stay ahead of the
audience and you want it to just move
but the wall stuff can be longer right
yeah oh yeah that's stuff we could yeah
yeah some i think as comedy writers we
get really excited about the wall
because it's like oh we get to be fancy
drama writers yeah and like what theme
should we do this time but like with the
comedy stuff if you could tell everybody
gets talked so quickly because it's
either like
um cut the jokes or have people talk
quickly and when like talk faster we
don't want to cut any of this stuff
that's what the cast said they said our
notes in the room are uh louder and
faster yeah yes yes laughter is always
hard for me with corvo because it's like
i'm going into like this i get like talk
very deep and and then when i have to
scream like that it just shreds my vocal
cords and then i have to i have to have
at least three days of like vocal rest
before i can do morty again wait justin
i see a lot of people like let me try to
do morty right now
okay
rick oh come here rick wait you'll hear
how rough it is hey rick can i ask you a
question i've got so you know how bad
that is yeah it's like vegas morning
it's gone it's gone it's vegas it's
vegas in vegas a weekend event in vegas
so
and corvo's like i can do corvo fine
it's like terry i need to ask you a
question our ship is broken and you're
and you're pissing on the floor in the
kitchen and then you know whatever he
says but and then rick i could do any
time but like i could do but the problem
is i do get it i get i get to a point
when corvo's screaming a lot where i
it's just gone i'm like i i can't i
can't anymore it's gone like because it
will start to sound weird
if i'm screaming as corvo at a certain
point my vocal chords people online say
that corvo and rick sound the same to
them and i'm like i don't see it like
wait give us our corvo and give us a
round okay okay uh
this is corvo uh i'm very upset my
teammates are failing our mission we are
trying to leave earth
uh and then uh morty come here
let me uh
let me just ruffle your hair a little
bit just just just turn around don't
look at me don't look me in the eye turn
around and again my voice is [ __ ] so
you really channel a beautiful man when
you do rick yeah yeah just morty turn
around and let me just i'm not gonna
hurt you just let me ruffle your hair oh
geez rick why why it doesn't make any
sense why why do you want to ruffle my
hair
no morty look i'm not you got to trust
me here i just want to ruffle your hair
it's nothing weird
i know it's it's see i know you i i know
it's probably you know whatever and like
and then so but like my morty the only
one of those three right now that's just
completely out the window is morty
and i'm gonna have to come out of comic
con and just like literally and i have a
record on monday
it's i know i'm kind of in a sh i'm in a
it's in my video game and it's just like
i i i'm one of the main voices in the
video game and i've still got two like
eight hour record days for that and
that's kind of a closer to morty voice i
was gonna say to you a these are all
first world problems a hundred percent
yeah these are champagne problems i am
not complaining in a way 100 i will say
like i'm so grateful and like yeah no bs
like i i um i lose my voice at comic-con
every time and i have to do things each
day and by saturday i'm usually [ __ ]
yeah yeah like and it's it's gravelly
yeah but
and that's even if you're that's even if
you're not going out and drinking and
partying that's like just working do we
don't do it all not at all i'm gonna say
that no
i was gonna say though if you had a
party last night at a hotel rooftop um
it's not like it's loud and you're
screaming at people you know yeah
exactly listen i love the wall like
every fan of this show and i'm just so
curious do you envision the wall story
line is it something that is continuing
into season four is it something that's
going to be with us for the length of
the show have you thought about that um
we
when we first developed the show we were
like you know
the first season can be the wall story
line the second season will be a new
sci-fi thing third season like that as
well and then we finished first season
we were like wait we love the wall this
story isn't over and then we loved
making it second season obviously we
loved making it third season third
season it changes speed a little bit at
the end of it with the rise of that kind
of dude nefarious theocracy it's just
it's i i mean yeah keep going sorry so
good fourth season i can tell you
it's sherry dealing with the rise of the
theocracy in the wall and it's got the
new tone of it if first season was kind
of like a war of the roses escape from
new york kind of like you know game of
thrones and second season was like a
murder mystery trapped in the backyard
a third season was uh was like yeah like
monsters in the bottom of the wall and
then like kind of tying up some loose
ends with tim and and getting to the
next phase
and then this next season is kind of a
tinker tailor soldier spy like cold war
cold war spy thriller in the wall
with the theocracy it's such a cool
little microcosm of humanity that's so
far removed from today's like insanity
in politics but we can play with the
human condition and i don't know i just
yeah i like i'm so i'm so in love with
what has been done in the wall it's it's
anyway it's also all of the most fun
tropes from movies and books and comics
that we love
like distilled into this thing that is
insane that it exists in a comedy yeah
it's almost like
remember we originally talked about it
being like if itchy and scratchy was
taking over the simpsons yeah and like
or one of the mcbain movies if you had
an entire mcbaner movie
like in a season of the simpsons that's
kind of what the wall is yeah i would
just say silver cops which we introduced
in season three
is also will also continue mike walked
in and was like i have this idea for
silver cops and i have four seasons all
already ready silver cops is so
that that's sort of why i keep i've said
a couple times like i feel like
season three is amazing but once you get
right into the middle of it from the
middle all the way to the end it just
the show is elevated to a level that i
feel like we've never hit and and that's
that's saying something because i think
the show's amazing and i'm biased
obviously but like also we have 99 ships
and that's no no and that's right that's
right around where i think it starts to
really well even before that but like
that's where it just like you start to
really start to see that there's there's
more going on with these schlorpians
there's more
there's there's there's like some
canonical like serialized [ __ ] to learn
about these ridiculously episodic
characters
and and then yeah mike silver cop thing
is just like whole oh my god it's so
good
like the end of the season also ends on
a cliffhanger for the solars as well
right where i don't think we're allowed
to spoil it but it's something like
completely uh off out of their comfort
zone that happens that they realize they
have to do for the family um but i was
gonna say with silver cops like one of
the fun things that happened is like
remember we were starting to write the
wall we just got really excited about it
mike walked in he's like what if we do
that again with like another storyline
we're like a hundred percent yeah let's
do a million of those but um there's
some really cool stuff coming with
silver cops one of the things in season
three early in the season you have an
episode that ties into the next one and
there's a joke that continues yeah um
which i i found very funny um is is that
like a one-off do you envision anything
where it's going to be
you know
for solar it's always like everybody
making it is a huge fan of tv and we've
all written tv and the first thing we
got to do we've never done before is
binge drop right so changed how we made
the show that's where the original wall
stuff was able to come in and then as he
dropped the line thing with the line
yeah
and then it was like every season we're
like well since we have no rules let's
break all the old rules so like standing
in line for a whole episode was a bit of
our like our seinfeld waiting to get
into the restaurant episode you know but
then crossing the two episodes is like a
very solar opposites weird thing to do
like we can get away with that so yeah
we're always gonna be pushing we have
fun stuff in season four too that's just
like how can we play with the format
and i think i think in the room too the
more like somebody laughs on something
that's like it feels like we're in
trouble almost and we're like we're not
supposed to do that with tv and then if
like everybody starts laughing like
let's just [ __ ] do it let's put it in
that is the best [ __ ] way to make a
show because i've been on so many shows
where everyone's crying laughing and
then it's like no but seriously but
seriously but seriously no no but
seriously let's really and it's like no
[ __ ] that uh and i just want to say like
i i'm so grateful to have these guys
like on the show like i sincerely it's
like i i i know it sounds like syrupy
and sappy but like i i really i like it
i'm so [ __ ] grateful and lucky and
just like i'm like how the [ __ ] is this
real and
what is anything you know it's just
incredible like
like yeah it's just [ __ ] amazing one
of the things i commend you guys on and
i think it's one of the reasons why i
love the show and why a lot of fans love
the show is that every episode anything
can happen like literally yeah so like
you could be five minutes in and all of
a sudden it's taking a turn i did not
see coming staying ahead of the audience
yeah yeah we try to like weaponize that
word josh tell him how annoying i am
about that no no i can feel josh getting
ready no there's a reason for that no it
is one as mike says one of his he knows
we're in the we're in a uh going down
the right direction when he'll pitch
something and now we're in zoom so i'll
move my chair back
and be like i'm across your arms i'm
about to say we can't do that and i'm
like yeah we got to do that and i think
we do try with with each season
especially one episode like uh the the
wooden city in the second second season
and this season we have that episode
where
it starts at something and then one of
them's on a daylight sylvester stallone
thing and it just we always try to do at
least with a couple episodes really at
some point turn it in a way
that people would never expect every
five minutes it changes right yeah it's
like it's almost like seasons or
something like you can't predict what's
gonna happen one
one act later in solar opposites but
that's like
it is so like we want we never want the
audience to feel like they know what's
coming yeah because it's also you can
rewatch it 100 times and you're like oh
wait
this is the episode where it ends up
here like it's just so fun yeah this is
the same thing on on rick and morty for
the most part where it's like i'll
forget what episode a thing is in i'm
like wait what episode is the thing
where we did the
like for example like a butter robot
joke i'm like what the [ __ ] episode was
the butter robot thing in and i'm just
like
yeah yeah and it's like i i i and so and
that was the pluto but it's like i
literally anyway that's a whole other
show but yeah that was the pluto episode
i was gonna say one thing that like most
people might not know when in the
writing process is like
we we have such a magic dance between
like the writers the cast the editors
the animators like every level adds
something to the show so it's like we we
start with an idea and then we pass it
off to the cast and then we pass it off
to the animators and like the storyboard
artist the supervisory director
yeah and basically asking i mean we're
asking our our animators and our
storyboard artists sometimes to do three
shows
right so we have salt the solar then we
have the wall that's totally different
and now we've asked them to do silver
cops i think we have the best color team
in the business like yeah yeah like when
the wall first was coming in the color
team on that made it its own world in a
way i'd never seen and it fueled us to
be like we need to spend more time in
that world exactly right and it's like
everybody adds their own the story just
changes and elevates every way and then
we will we'll find that like affecting
the writing too with the color or like
we'll get cast members and then we'll
just blow us away with how they
interpreted a character we're like well
now we got to bring that storyline back
it's amazing like season one like really
figuring out the wall it was like um it
was weirdly easy and challenging in a
good way yeah yeah we had big meetings
where it was like uh you know mendel you
know r.i.p love the man uh he was there
and we would just sit and talk about the
wall i think it felt like the wall was
like the solars were just easy it was
like
something that's never other show i've
had to deal with
maps and maps of the wall keeping track
of it yeah yeah yeah bird's eye because
yeah we'll turn into a script and the
artist will go you can't do that no i
haven't like why it's like because that
part of the wall doesn't connect to that
part and i have damn it right on season
one we had to literally build a token
of where the different thing i mean and
obviously it was like a little hand wavy
but it was enough where it was like okay
we this is good enough to get away with
for season one the only show i've
encountered that on is star trek because
they're like well that's not where the
neutral zone is and i'm like crap [ __ ]
yeah you're right and then it's like
weirdly the wall you know yeah yeah i
love that though
in season four with that is where
everything is in the wall becomes a a
huge storyline
in our world there's been a cut even in
three i think that there's some stuff in
three when you find out well i don't
want to yeah you find out what's really
going on with these murders and i had
it's location related and it's like i
had a disease thought the other day that
i didn't even tell you guys yet where i
was like
what if the people in the wall start
making a little story in their wall
so that there's like a show and a show
oh my god and i was like
should i say that out loud to them
because i know they're going to be into
it yeah this is the show you say
everything out loud what if somehow i
mean who care hand wave it away somehow
they get some camera equipment and like
the ability to like that's yeah dude and
then now there's a sitcom in the dude
it's like okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
that's season five hey see can see after
we get well after things settle down can
we do a season where it's just like a
total like network uh it's like straight
it's literally like what's the apple
show the morning show like not like
dealing with like you mean like a news
show well no wait it's literally we
create our own network yeah it's it's
it's it's it's literally like a drama
built around like you know ratings you
know what i would love to do that
the wall i would love to do what is the
what is the abc of the wooden city and
you like build out an entire oh my god i
want to see anyway listen this is sorry
everybody i just forget you heard all
that yeah cause like honestly this might
i feel i feel like we're literally
probably this is not a good idea to be
maybe cut some of that [ __ ] right i i
can i can also edit out stuff
don't just leave it
who cares we may or may not whatever i
was also going to say and i got a rap
but the other thing is you can put on a
talk show in the wall there's you could
start filming movies in the wall really
excited about uhf uh weird house movie
but you know maybe a little more
dramatic because it's the wall in the
wall
yeah like with where they're like
casting but we love it's world building
it's right um there's also something to
think about real quick and then i'll go
is this bringing in the um
uh the main cast into the wall somehow
interacting in a movie in the wall
there's so many i'm just waiting for not
a smart little guffman but like
one day the solars will encounter the
people in the wall truly because they do
a little bit but like hulu needs to buy
a two-hour epic movie from us
this show
would be able to slam dunk a [ __ ]
movie hardcore slam dunk you heard it
right here first of all cupid does film
things in the wall the people yeah
oh the pupa presents the pupils hey by
the way
by the way this is what it is what must
happen in the writer's room we're
witnessing he'll understand
during this interview okay listen
we have to wrap but even though i could
talk to you for another hour i'm just
going to say for everyone watching watch
solar opposites it's on hulu it does at
least good enough to get a season four
they don't tell me anything about the
numbers they don't tell us either but we
only knew from season one and and then
we kind of did me and mike did a little
bit of you know our own reconnaissance
missions a lot of people are watching
the show it's a lot of people watching
this we love everybody who's watching
the show so if there's people who aren't
watching the show please watch it it's
tell them to watch it it's free if
you're a fan of rick and morty you will
love this show i really think i mean i
would say eighty percent of rick and
morty fans will love this it's the
simple
friendly husband alien
uh uh story in the world
rick and morty yeah tiffany haddish
plays an ai oh we know what we're
talking about yeah tiffany haddish is so
[ __ ] good okay anyway so good we love
you tiffany there's a lot of people we
want to say we love that i was just
going to say enjoy comic-con thank you
so much for stopping by if there's
anything we can do on collider to help
you guys out please let me know thank
you thank you appreciate it